con efecto inmediato al consejo de
ministros de etiopía declaró el estado
de emergencia en todo el país una medida
que se mantendrá por seis meses
lutz arbás lynch ha puesto la
declaración de estado de emergencia se
presentará a la cámara de representantes
del pueblo en un plazo de 48 horas y se
promulgará sin embargo su aplicación
comenzó hoy desde el momento en que fue
declarada por el consejo de ministros de
kapersky sitio
para festram y jon al mal el estado de
emergencia permite entre otras cosas
controles de carretera toques de queda y
la toma del control militar las
autoridades de la capital addis abeba
anunciaron además que los residentes
debían registrar sus armas en los
próximos dos días y prepararse para
defender la ciudad la medida se toma
después de que los combatientes rebeldes
de la región norteña de tigre asegurarán
en los últimos días haber capturados
ciudades estratégicas a unos 300
kilómetros de la capital este martes
también el presidente estadounidense joe
biden retiró a etiopía de un programa de
acceso comercial referente al acusar a
addis abeba de graves violaciones de
derechos humanos en ese sentido el
enviado especial norteamericano para el
cuerno de áfrica instó a todas las
partes a permitir la entrada de ayuda
humanitaria
'el tigre' la región del norte de
etiopía es un desastre no somos capaces
de hacer llegar nuestros camiones no
somos capaces de hacer llegar nuestro
combustible no sé cómo la gente no está
muy bien informada en las fuerzas de
tigre han estado luchando contra el
gobierno durante el último año en una
guerra que ha cobrado miles de muertos y
según advirtió el pasado mes el programa
mundial de alimentos casi siete millones
de personas enfrentan actualmente una
crisis de hambre